my move University YouTube videos are
offered on a pay what you like basis if
you'd like to pay for the use of the
videos visit my website at move
University comm click on the pay what
you like link at the top of the page and
follow the instructions on that page
thank you and enjoy ethanol ethyl
alcohol humans drink it they've been
drinking it for ages and we know it
causes health problems and I kind of
want to sort of bring up this one that
relates to fatty acid synthesis
excessive alcohol consumption and
leading to moving to fatty liver so the
first thing we need to know about
ethanol is that it cannot be excreted in
our urine it needs to be metabolized in
fact you're in drug tests do not
actually test for ethanol they test for
the metabolites of it one of those is
ethyl gluco urinate also known as etg i
really don't know too much about that if
you're interested maybe conduct a google
search of that but the point is that it
must be metabolizing one of the key ways
that ethanol is metabolized in the liver
is in these two steps here excuse me so
ethanol is first converted to
acetaldehyde in which this is an
oxidation reaction here and the enzyme
that catalyzes this reaction is called
alcohol dehydrogenase and we've actually
seen this enzyme before in alcohol
fermentation but in that case alcohol
dehydrogenase catalyzed the reverse
reaction so as to regenerate NAD+ or by
pollicis in this case we're making nadh
because we're going towards the
acetaldehyde so this gives us an NADH
and which we know of course can give us
energy and then in the mitochondria the
acetaldehyde can be further oxidized to
acetate by acetaldehyde dehydrogenase
and that of course uses an nad plus to
give us an NADH and so we get NADH out
of this so whatever like who cares
what's the significance here well the
significance is that with excessive
alcohol consumption this will be
happening a lot like a lot so no so
level a crazy buildup of NADH
which increases the NADH to NAD+ ratio
now this NADH NAD+ ratio can cause a
multitude of problems and I'm not going
to go into all of them some of them I'll
just mention them here briefly like
hypoglycemia hyperglycemia there can be
ketoacidosis all those different things
that they all have to do with excessive
alcohol consumption but I'm not going to
talk about all those I'm only going to
talk about how this ratio effects fat
metabolism so this buildup of NADH what
it causes or it does is it does two
things it inhibits beta oxidation and it
allows fatty acid synthesis to occur so
the question is how does that actually
happen well if you recall in beta
oxidation we created a bunch of fadh2s
and nadh s so if we're already having
you know if we have an excessive alcohol
consumption we have these reactions
occurring frequently write all these
dehydrogenase reactions occurring we
have a we're using up a lot of nad plus
s and making a lot of nadh s we have a
buildup of nadh then beta oxidation
doesn't need to happen right because
then we have plenty of NADH we don't
need to make more right and beta
oxidation would then be inhibited
there's no sense in creating more if
there's already play around right so so
what's the deal here then so now we have
a buildup of this high NADH we've
already said that it inhibits beta
oxidation for the reason that I just
mentioned another thing is that these
high NADH level signal plenty of what I
call energy to be so we know that these
NADH is are worth two and a half ATP
with reoxidized electron transport chain
so they represent soon to be energy
right soon to be ATP or energy to be as
I put it so if there's a bunch of this
NADH that means that this could be
sensed as a sort of high energy state
right which is the type of state that
you want if you want fatty acid
synthesis to occur right fatty acid
synthesis as a form of is a way to store
energy right
or we would store energy only when we
have plenty of it so high NADH levels
indicate that high energy to be to the
it sense as a high energy state and so
fatty acid synthesis will occur in the
liver and that will be followed by
triglyceride synthesis or fat synthesis
in the liver as well so we're restoring
this the the energy as fat in fatty
acids and followed by storing them as I
strike with riser fats and this is
happening the liver so like I said we
have to emphasize this point of
excessive alcohol consumption this could
happen a lot and over time and this
would this can causes us can cut this
this buildup of fat over time and
progression what can happen is it can
lead to this thing called fatty liver
which is really just excessive fat
storage in liver and this kid damaged
liver cells and of course if the liver
cells are damaged they might not be able
to work is properly or as well and it
might even cause depending on the
severity it could cause cell death and
liver cell death is obviously a problem
your liver is incredibly important for a
variety of reasons including maintaining
your blood glucose levels and and
detoxifying poisons that poisons that
enter your body so if your if your liver
is not working liver failure can happen
is that's washing that's the definition
of liver failure your liver not working
the way it should that that could that
could be a serious problem that could
lead in death lead to death so this is
why this is one of the reasons one of
the the many reasons that excessive
alcohol consumption can be detrimental
to one's health so I hope that video was
helpful and interesting in this in that
in that it's a clinical correlate to the
topic of fatty acid synthesis thank you
for watching